and that's about it really bees getting
car and things like that huh
we're just we just below you can we're
gonna try to land on diction like I
missed god damn it oh [ __ ] do your night
sweet prince
oh hey do whatever you want with my body
following him is I keep forgetting how
to use a damn please just pull down oh
I'm dead no I'm fine I'm fine I'm fine
hey guys I put my parachute in the lasso
hey wait for me
can we all stand up I'll just grab punky
see if you can stand on it don't tell me
okay huh wait I will ask you please jump
on the stupid truck there we go
oh yeah ha ha ha
later dudes that turbo holy [ __ ] I'm
sorry I did I didn't mean to do it
where's to the boat alright let's go
let's return now get I I can appreciate
that but perfection good
can someone jump in again everywhere is
so damn fast holy [ __ ] that's amazing
ray guess I did why did you jump off why
did you go to space helicopter how do I
get to you
oh really oh my oh oh ah I'm good me and
Erica wait wait wait with the helicopter
I'm coming without me I am n let's go
wait how do I go you're fine don't worry
about it
like this is a sling we go in the back
run jump pain you're in you're in it huh
okay chuckle I don't know how to shoot I
jumped out I'm sorry I didn't jump
higher than goddamn it okay she beauty
assistance right ever stupid oh god damn
it
geez what am i doing why oh sorry
oh you playing okay all mine coming stay
there Oh cubs I'm gonna swan dive inside
you inside your bud okay I kept missing
I'm really hurt there we go all right
drive faster gonna change it on it
faster faster lovely yeah baby what the
hell is in this boat
I see a mixer god damnit it's bad
oh Jesus Christ what are you doing what
do you know you're crazy
oh you took the palm tree with you I'm
just sleeping I'm just fine
yeah whatever what am I like yeah of
course I'm a lie of course I don't
Jesus Christ is real things on Lenin I
got a I got a steal a plane or some [ __ ]
yeah it's like Oh yep there I'm getting
in a plane [ __ ] yet oh Jesus cries I'm
not a pilot
what the hell what is up with these
planes they're like drifting and [ __ ] up
up my plane goes every direction but up
there how does it go up how do you go up
oh my god am I gonna die
we're nice dude he's been glued back
together inhale it just Jesus cries haha
I'm going oh my god
I'm play I just kept going forever
yeah buddy forever okay I'm gonna brown
your play I have no idea what's going on
how do I fight this thing oh I don't
have steaks I can do it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I'm in trouble
alright they're like dirt bikes or
whatever they might well be alright
there should be we'll have a look let me
get my land like a boss thank you see
your help oh there are there are a dirt
fighter awesome let's have a proper race
okay okay well let's wait for all of us
to be in the car and then we just raised
on three one two two three dog Davis
Creek swam don't let's start ever if you
hold shift you say your car just like
goes to space man holy [ __ ]
oh my god right I'm literally flying
ice-o-pede Oh what I exploded get it put
your arms around me whoa hey Wow nice oh
jesus oh Jesus
alright come on George Evie do it okay
sign by that tree right in front and
I'll do the charge right into you okay
okay oh my god what happened to you do
you survive how do you survive what's
happening you're lagging oh god you're
you're walking in there you're walking
to heavens oh no oh no oh I'm gonna
check out the casino while you guys are
this guy here's guys guy right
me I can tell ya oh it's cute no it's
not oh nice it's so creepy when you
respawn you just come out of the ground
yeah what kill it
everyone die I don't ever recall skiing
in this game though get out Timmy change
now get out Timmy Jen I'll make him go
out stupid [ __ ]
there we go he's all we could write it
let's ride him over oh so you get for
having our card [ __ ] that's how you
ride snowmobiles kill him
what is he doing I'll bet hey come on
use shift activate shift Oh guys wait
for me
Rizzy feeling oh Jesus coffee
you almost killed me this is skiing huh
yeah